the trailer looks great really looking
forward to the season um i love learning
about the behind the scenes the making
of shows and movies uh what do you think
might surprise fans to learn about the
actual behind the scenes of the making
of star trek discovery
uh well for season for season four i
don't think it would surprise anyone to
learn how challenging it was it was it
was a very very challenging season just
on every level we we're
obviously a very big show we were one of
the first shows to go back into
production so it was um
uh just challenging on on every level
and it took everything from all of our
cast and crew the entire team to
do it and make it safe and everyone just
did an amazing job so
yeah it's like it's after the experience
of season four it's hard to talk about
you know behind the scenes challenges of
any other season right
um because here we are you know in this
pandemic just you know struggling doing
our best together so yeah i did him i
mean
yep
[Laughter]
one of the things that i love about star
trek is when it is not you know a
villain but the the crew coming together
to overcome an obstacle like an anomaly
where there's science and you're
figuring things out can you i guess what
can you tease about the upcoming season
well i think
the anomaly is really um there's a lot
of art imitating life and life imitating
art here uh with season four we're very
excited to share it for for that reason
and many other reasons but i it's really
about how uh you know in the story it's
how these people navigate uncertainty
and how they uh further solidify their
roles uh in this on this ship with each
other um and even how they solidify the
under their understanding of themselves
in the midst of this uncertainty and
danger
that comes with it as well
so i i've said this before about the
show and it's kudos to to michelle and
to everyone else but i feel like no
stones are left unturned
uh do you want to add anything
i i i don't think i could have said it
any better actually so
um uh one of the things that what i i
really enjoy that the fact that this
show takes place in a completely
different time than any other star trek
for both of you what's your favorite
part about the series taking place so
far in the future
um well from the the storytelling
standpoint and coming up with the
stories what i love is uh is what i
really loved going into season three
which continues into season four which
is just the fresh snow of it all uh
we're kind of we're creating canon as
we're riding it while also of course
honoring all of the canon that has come
before so
there's there's just a lot of freedom in
that and a lot of places to play and a
lot of places to um explore characters
and different species in new ways and uh
just as a as a fan of trek myself that's
that's a lot of fun
yeah i love the technology i love
what we've done with programmable matter
i have to shout out ala tunde ash and
sandman who's one of our executive
producers and our producing director
and um i i i the genesis of it was was
you know birthed out of his brilliant
mind and in the brilliant mind of
michelle paradise and alex kurtzman
coming together to like further develop
it and everything it's become quite a
tenant of the technology of this new
future and i i love it i love it i love
it really cool yeah
i i'm a big fan of the fact that there's
a cat that's a prominent part of the
show um
i am curious uh if grudge has a big
bigger
bigger part this season and uh are there
any other pets joining the show
well i guess we can spoil it here we did
set up burnham's captain but in the
first episode it is grudge so she seeds
the chair to grudge
did i spoil that
yeah and it's a tough scene you know it
is right yeah yeah yeah um
well
grudge it does reappear uh yes in uh
season four i can't say if there are any
other um
uh
furry like friends but
we might see one or two
i absolutely love it i i definitely have
an individual question what does it mean
for you to be um
the captain and to
i mean it's awesome it really is awesome
and i'm just curious if you could talk
about that
well yeah it's it's awesome it literally
strikes me with awe
um because i
i already have such an appreciation such
a deep respect um such a sense of
privilege and and honor um to have the
the blessing of this story in this
franchise
considering what it means um the impact
it's already made but being the first
black woman helming it but then also the
first you know black
female captain i
i'm never going to be able to talk about
it enough right i'm never going to be
able to talk about
what it really means to me and and
what i know it it means to to others
um
when i talk about it in truth it just
makes me cry so i end up having to just
kind of say man it's awesome and like
leave it at that because i can't keep
crying in every interview and on every
panel um but it's huge it's huge being
cemented in history in this way
um in in television history in this way
especially standing on the shoulders
that i stand on
yeah i love it um listen can't wait to
see the season i gotta stop uh good luck
with the rest of your interviews today
thank you thank you so much